what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and yesterday you might
have seen or at least heard of some
spider-man no way home photos
circulating around some photos that
involve tom holland spider-man toby
maguire spider-man and andrew garfield
spider-man all appearing in the same
photo and then a second photo that had
charlie cox's matt murdock with
spider-man happy hogan and aunt may at a
dinner table now yesterday the big
question was are these photos real or
are they fake and i didn't mention
yesterday the person who posted these
photos online because i didn't want to
get this person in any type of trouble
however this person john campbell did
come out on his own show yesterday and
he did say
he put him out and what he thought they
actually were but then he talked about
his experience
afterwards dealing with a certain studio
that begins with an s aka sony so in
today's video we're gonna break down
what actually happened and if these
photos are indeed real or fake and if
you are a spider-man fan be sure to
subscribe to my channel and cosmic
culture so you can enter the giveaway to
win this spider-man action figure all
you gotta do is subscribe to both
channels and leave some comments on some
recent videos now like i said i wouldn't
say that it was john campia if one
everybody didn't already know and two he
went on his own show live and said it
himself and talked about what happened
and whether or not these photos are real
or fake he himself hinted at a very
specific answer one that fans would
probably like however i'll go over
everything break it down and then you
can decide for yourself at the end on
whether or not you think these photos
are real or fake so first let me explain
the situation last night john campio
posted two photos that were from
spiderman no way home one like i
mentioned had the three spiderman in it
the other like i mentioned had matt
murdock with happy aunt may and peter
and of course the entire internet
immediately lost their minds now here's
the kicker right after john campio
posted these he deleted them five
minutes later it's also worth noting
that he put his watermark on the photos
this is important and we'll come back to
that in a bit but yesterday he explained
exactly what happened apparently he
thought the photos were actually faked
he examined the photos and he thought
that the lighting was a little bit off
and that these are just really good
photoshops and he mentioned that he had
posted photoshopped pictures before and
they got a lot of attention on twitter
but it was known that they were fake so
he thought this was kind of the same
thing however it wasn't because this is
what he had to say on his show yesterday
i post it and then five minutes later i
get this call from somebody i won't say
who saying that yeah uh these pictures
are probably real then i'm like are you
sure and like uh look i don't know 100
for sure but i feel pretty comfortable
saying that these are most likely real
and i'm like well crap so i immediately
jumped back on twitter again only about
five minutes had passed and i delete
them immediately which he did but we all
know how the internet is if you post
something within seconds of it going out
especially if it's something related to
spider-man knowing home people have
screenshot it so of course the photos
made their way around online everywhere
but get this he was actually going to
share more pictures two more pictures to
be specific he was just going to kind of
space them out and if he thinks that
these first two photos were real then
these next two were probably real here's
what he had to say about that there were
more pictures there were more than the
two i put up there were indeed i wanna
say four and i was going to post the
other pictures as well i was going to
wait another five minutes and then post
the other picture and then i was going
to wait another five minutes and post
the other picture i obviously didn't
share the other two pictures and the
other two pictures are the more juicy
ones that's all i'm going to tell you is
that the other two pictures were the
more juicy ones but now that i know that
there's a strong possibility that
they're real i am not going to be
posting those now this gets rather
interesting because like i said jon said
that he posted these thinking that they
truly were fake and i do believe that
because he also put his watermark on
them and if you're gonna leak something
that big why would you put your
watermark on it he's a smart guy he
wouldn't do that however and
unfortunately it looks like these could
very well be real because he goes on to
say this about talking with sony i was
talking to one of the studio reps today
i'll say studio that has the letter s in
it and they basically said to me like i
assume you thought these things were
fake because you put your watermark on
it i don't expect that you would try to
steal the mona lisa and then leave your
business card behind for the cops to
call you and i'm like yes if i had
thought they were real and i was going
to share them online i would absolutely
not put my watermark on it so everybody
knew that the leak came from me and yes
of course that's a no-brainer if you're
really gonna leak something you
shouldn't be putting your name on it
that's asking for feige and all the
other big guns to come right after you
but here's the thing that is actually
really interesting about this statement
the rep that he spoke with at sony said
i assume you thought these things were
fake doesn't that heavily imply that
they're real
i'm not saying that it's confirmed but
kind of sounds like it now look there is
the possibility that toby and andrew are
appearing in this film but this photo is
fake however people could believe it's
real and know that toby and andrew are
in the film that could be a reason that
sony and other studios could be mad but
i mean at this point in time so many
things have leaked stating that andrew
and toby are indeed in the film all of
these things would have to be false all
of these supposed leaks probably in the
50s would have to be false literally
like 50 big leagues would all have to be
false but i kind of admire what sony is
doing even though they know that we know
they're not gonna tell us they're not
gonna show us until we actually go into
the movie which makes the anticipation
super high now like i said john's a
smart guy i don't think he ever meant to
do any harm to the studios to anybody
online that was trying to avoid leaks he
himself has spoken up before about how
he doesn't like how people spoil things
and put leaks out there he doesn't mind
them himself but he wouldn't ever try to
ruin it for the masses but jon did kind
of end up his stream by saying this i
got sent these pictures i thought they
were fake i slapped my watermark on it
because i wanted credit for sharing them
put them up as soon as i heard that they
could be real i deleted them immediately
and i didn't even share all the pictures
so two things one is that there are more
pictures and i am about to talk about
those because he talks about those but
two even though he says that he thought
they were fake he does say he heard that
they could be real and again the sony
rep apparently told him i assume you
thought these were fake kind of implying
that they're actually real so i'll let
you decide if you think they're real or
fake but here is what he said about the
other two pictures that he didn't share
and again this is coming from him on his
live stream he said should i give you a
little tease into what was one of the
other pictures that you'll never be able
to deduce what the actual image is i'll
give you a little tease i'm gonna give
you a tease only because you'll never
guess or deduce what the actual picture
is it involves somebody in a mocap suit
now he's kind of right somebody in a
mocap suit that's pretty vague so the
only thing we really know is that it's
from spider-man knowing home and it
shows somebody in a mocap suit now this
could be anybody from the hulk to simply
perhaps tom holland wearing a mocap suit
for whatever reason rocking a new iron
spider suit or something it could be one
of the villains like the green goblin
doc ock or it could be someone that we
have zero idea is in the movie at this
point your guess is as good as mine so
let me know what you think about this in
the comments down below and let me know
do you think these photos are real or do
you think they're fake i believe you all
should know which side i'm leaning
towards but let me know how you feel
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe and for live updates you can
always follow me on instagram twitter
and tick tock and as always thank you
all so much for watching woof
you